So, yeah, welcome to the second lecture.
Today we will
talk about
robot control and Markov decision
processes. We also have received some
feedback from you for for the first
week. It turns out the first homework
assignment was maybe a little
challenging. So, we've extended the
deadline for that. We've also created a
Moodle forum where you can ask questions
and see if other students have asked the
same questions that our TAs will also
try to help and answer.
And
we have also
made our slides and recordings available
in case you didn't receive the password
to access the content. Here is the the
the login details that you need and this
will be the same for the future.
And
yeah, so let's get started for today.
So,
we'll start talking about robots because
one of the most exciting things about
robot learning right now is
the diversity of the hardware we are
dealing with, right? So, you've got
everything from quadrupeds
navigating in auto terrain to dexterous
hands
solving Rubik's Cube,
drones flying and so forth. And you
know, from the distance this looks like
completely different problems, right?
Like trying to control all these
different robots. Right? And so,
the core question is like how do we
actually control these very different
morphologies
because all of these robots have these
different like joints and actuators
and different physics, but they all you
know, kind of share the same
fundamental constraint that we want to
translate some sort of high-level goal
into specific motor torques required to
to that specific
morphology throughout the world. And
to build this kind of general foundation
model for robotics,
we can't just like try to solve it for
one robot, but we have to understand the
underlying framework for robot control
that applies to all of them.
And
um
So, looking at all these different
robots from the last slide,
how do we find a common language to
describe what they're actually doing,
right? And it turns out that most of
them, almost all all of them, you can
describe as a collection of rigid rigid
bodies
transforming
or moving through space.
What this means is
we assume
in this mathematical framework that the
robot is
a rigid body, meaning that the distance
between two points on the robot remains
constant.
So, this means that it doesn't like
squish or or or stretch while moving.
And
one of the benefits of this is that we
essentially only want have to track one
point on the robot instead of like
multiple.
And so, here on the left you can see how
this would look like for
like a planner motion. So, if you have
like a car or like a robot that's like
navigating on the ground, you would
describe this would be like mostly
represented by its motion in XY and
maybe like an orientation. And so, you
would describe this using like the SE2
group, so the special Euclidean group.
And it's kind of simple, but you know,
it's like the fundamentals for like
ground motion.
Now, for
for something like drones, this would
that
live in the full 3D world, you would
describe this with SE3. This is
spatial motion. And so, here now you add
um a zip for for altitude
um and also like free rotational axis um
roll pitch and and yaw.
Um
this is probably like familiar with most
of you, but just to kind of go through
the basics again, so everybody's on the
same point. Um how do we actually
represent these in our code? Uh we use
homogeneous transformation matrices.
Um on the left you see uh this um for
the SE3, um which is now 3° of freedom
as we said for the X Y and then the
uh theta, um
and um we represent this with a rotation
matrix uh built from sines and cosines
as well as a uh translation um
uh translational vector.
Um and on the on the right side you see
kind of the the the equivalent for for
the drone or for the SE3,
um where we scale this um to 6° of
freedom and now we have um like six
values uh for the translation and and
three for for rotation. Um and like one
maybe one thing to um kind of like uh
sanity check on the math here um is that
in order for these matrices to be valid
um rotation matrices, they have to
satisfy two properties.
Uh first uh matrix needs to be uh
orthogonal, um
um
so meaning that it's transpose is equal
um to its inverse. And then the second
is that it also needs to have a
determinant of one.
And so this is not like, you know, like
a metric, but just
uh ensures that when our like when the
robot like rotates, um you know, it
doesn't like accidentally stretch or or
anything, so it remains a true uh rigid
body.
Okay, uh why do we care about all these
matrices from the previous slide?
Because in the real world um the robot
like typically doesn't have just like
one frame,
uh but most probably like a whole uh
hierarchy of them.
Um so, look for example at the
self-driving car example.
Um so, the car has a base frame um
where this is like at the which which
sits at the center of its gravity, and
which we use to kind of like control and
send commands to the motor uh to the
car. Um but then it will have like some
sort of sensor like a lidar or a camera
on top um sitting on the roof. Um and
for example, now when the sensor
perceives like a pedestrian on the on
the road, um
like it will sense it in its local
coordinate. And uh in order for us to,
you know, like decide not to run over
this pedestrian, we need to transform it
back into our base frame where we are
doing all the control.
Um and um now the the beauty is that um
now we can like chain all this like uh
homogeneous transformation matrices to
simply do this this conversions from uh
like where is the pedestrian in the
sensor frame to where is it now in in
the base frame. Um and maybe like a side
note, actually, in order to like we will
not cover this in in this lecture, but
uh in order to determine how like the
transformation between the sensor frame
to the base frame is, like you would do
this via sensor calibration typically.
Um
All right.
So, um so far we've treated robot as uh
like a single rigid block moving through
the world. Um but in reality, like
robots are a bit more complex. Um for
example, if you look at this humanoid uh
Lola,
uh you know, um we will want to uh
define this as articulated uh rigid
bodies. Um so, this means that um this
will have now three components. Uh we
will have links um that um like are the
individual rigid bodies. Uh then joints
that connect the links, and then end
effectors,
uh which are like essentially um like
the
uh
like for example, the gripper, or like
the thing that you use to interact with
the world.
Um and the key the key takeaway here is
that um articulate robot uh is
essentially just like a chain of like
coordinate frames.
Um so, uh everything that you know we
just covered, like how to like convert
and like chain all these matrices, um
you would do this to find out for
example, where your hand is relative to
your humanoid's uh robot frame. You can
just like multiply and chain these
uh to com- do these computations.
Um looking at uh robot arm
articulations, um here is how this might
look for the Franka, um like a 7° of
freedom, um very popular kind of like uh
robot arm. Um
uh as well as the the SO1 uh 101, the
this is a robot that you will be using
in the group projects later on, and uh
you will see that, you know, despite the
the right one being a much simpler
robot, um you know, in principle, like
the definition is like very similar.
Um so, um from the mathematically, it's
like um pretty much the identical.
Okay. Um
so, we talked about how the arm moves,
but um
motion has to translate to interaction
in the real world, right? And um this
happens with the end effector. Um There
are like different types of end
effectors that one can use to interact
with the real world. I highlighted like
three different ones that are kind of um
um common and popular in robotics.
Uh on the left, you see uh the suction
gripper,
um which uh is from a learning
perspective a very uh clean uh action
space, cuz it's like binary.
Um so it's like either the vacuum is on
or off.
Um so you don't have to worry about any
like additional geometries. Um
and this is typically used in like
industrial like pick and place kind of
applications.
Um then in the middle is the parallel uh
gripper uh which is what you will find
uh that most of the
uh industrial robots um that are like
the Frankas and the SO110s use. Um that
you will be using. Um here, you know,
it's a 1° of freedom action and you have
to worry maybe about the width of the
object and requires a bit more precision
um to interact with objects. Uh and then
on the right we have uh the Dexters
hands
uh which uh are much more complex end
effectors. So instead of just having
like one or two degrees of freedom, you
might have like over 20.
Uh and as we move into MDPs later, um
these are how um these will affect how
your action space essentially uh
changes.
Um
okay. Uh
maybe briefly I'll cover uh joints. So
we've looked at the arm and hands, but
um
uh
so the joints um essentially
uh are like the mathematical constraint
that limits the the relative motion
between the two rigid bodies
um so that you can uh we can actually
control them. Uh here is
a diagram from um like a modern robotics
uh textbook. Um well, you see like kind
of the standard vocabulary of different
types of joint. Um honestly, the
pre- pretty much the most popular joint
that that you should care about and that
you will be using are the revolute
joints.
Uh um which allow rotation around a
single axis like your elbow.
Um
All right.
Let's talk about degrees of freedom. Um
and this is starting to get at the at
the to the core of why robot learning um
is so hard. Um so, how do we count the
total um of freedom
uh
the total amount of freedom that the
robot has to move in space?
Uh we call this uh the degrees of
freedom of the robot, and it essentially
uh defines the number of independent um
parameters that uh you would need to
define the
uh exact state of the robot at any given
uh time.
Um and so, here uh you can see how this
is defined for these different um
types of joints.
Um and in general, if you want to
calculate how many uh degrees of freedom
the
um uh a a certain robot has, you can use
this uh formula, this uh
Kutzbach
formula, where um
you start with the total uh number of
possible dimensions uh of your rigid
body, uh and then you subtract the
constraints um for for every
uh by every joint that that you have
added.
Um
Okay.
Now, we need to talk about the space
where all these parameters actually
live. Um we and we call this typically
the configuration space or the C-space.
Um this is essentially um the set of all
possible configurations
uh a robot can take. Um so, looking at
the table um
over here, you can see that the the
space depends entirely on the types of
joints that you have. So, for a point on
a plane, um it's simply like a Euclidean
space, but uh if you look at the like uh
two-R arm,
uh because it has two revolute joints,
um it's not going to be flat, uh but it
will be a torus.
Um
And so, this is kind of important
because um when we train our neural
network um Um, be a policy, the network
has to respect like the different
topologies that your uh robot
configuration space uh has.
Um, so for example, um in the torus
case, um so like the kind of the um
the distance between two points is is
not always like a straight line, right?
So if you're like at 356 and you want to
get to one, right? Like the shortest
path um
uh is like just a 2° and not like going
back like uh 350°
Um
Okay, so now the workspace, so we just
uh covered the C-space.
Um the Now we need to map this back into
the real world. Um So the workspace is
um the simply the set of all points that
the robot can reach um in the in the
physical world. Um and so
um we make this distinction in robot
learning because
um your agent will often live at two um
in two different worlds at once. Like uh
it will perceive the tasks in the
workspace, uh like seeing a cup on the
table, but um it will have to execute
the movement in the configuration space
by turning its joints. Um And so this
mapping is not uh trivial as we will see
in the next slides.
Um
because um
there is also, for example, obstacles,
right? Um and um for example, here this
Imagine in this like simplified kind of
uh a robot if we have this this blue
circle that represents an obstacle, um
that would translate to to this uh in
the configuration space of the robot,
right?
Um so this is kind of the forbidden
region that your, you know, like robot
joints uh should not uh reach. And it's
important to understand that this is how
robotics is used to do like motion
planning in the '90s and in the the
Um so the standard approach back then
was to explicitly construct this like
configuration spaces um and like
translate the obstacles into the
configuration space.
Um
and then search for a path that state,
you know, like in the in the free space.
Um
as you can see in the next slide.
Wait.
Um, right?
And so
um, in
but this like effectively doesn't scale
very well to to higher like the higher
the dimensions of your robot,
um it becomes like pretty much like
intractable to to do this computations.
Um, and so in modern robot learning,
uh we don't want to like pre-calculate
all this like shapes and obstacles and
have like perfect like structured
uh world um
state. We want to kind of like have a
policy that can like learn how to to
feel like where the obstacles are like
implicitly. Um, recognizing
automatically that certain like actions
will lead to uh regions um of like bad
outcomes, right?
Um, so this is kind of like the
fundamental difference between um you
know, uh hardcoded like geometry to
um learned representations that we'll be
discussing in the rest of the term.
Um, maybe to finalize this kind of
definitions let's talk briefly about the
task space. Um, the task space for a
robot is um essentially the manifold
where the objective um
um is naturally defined. Um, so and this
is like independent of the embodiment.
Um, so for example, uh if the task is to
uh
clean uh this whiteboard, um the the
task space will be uh all the surface of
that all the points on the surface of
that whiteboard. And doesn't matter if
this is like a a humanoid, a mobile
single arm manipulator, or a or a flying
drone that that is going to like
wipe the
the surface of that.
All right.
Um question time. So, now we've covered
like quite a bit of concepts.
Uh so, maybe to make sure that you all
understand um how these are applied, uh
let's look at the Franka robot and maybe
discuss with your uh neighbor for like
uh half a minute or 20 seconds
uh what the configuration,
uh workspace, and uh task space could
be.
Okay, it's it's fine. Like we we we
don't have time to figure it out.
Um
So, the configuration space is uh the
Yeah.
Does this align Does the Does this align
with what you thought?
>> It it aligns. No, wait.
>> Perfect score.
Um
yeah, sorry about that. Um so, yeah, we
have the uh 7 degrees of freedom uh
manifold for the configuration space.
Um the workspace, uh as we said before,
is like all the physically reachable
state uh space in
um
XYZ. And the task space will be like the
six-dimensional pose of the end
effector.
Um here you can see how the workspace
looks. Maybe like one uh thing that is
important that we will be be covering
now also is
um that because, as we discussed before,
the the task space is smaller than the
configuration space, this uh leads to
the redundancy and null space motion.
So, this means that um
uh for example, if the robot is holding
a uh
a mug of coffee like perfectly still, um
there are many different ways for it to
move the elbow while maintaining the
same fixed point of the uh end effector
um in
in space. So, this allows you also to
plan around obstacles, for example.
All right.
We've defined our spaces. Now, we need
to cover how we move between them. So,
the most fundamental mapping
is called forward kinematics.
This is like answering the question of
imagine you already know all the joint
values of your robot of this arm.
How do you
compute where your end effector is?
Right? So, so given given like all these
three values, like where is like your
end effector?
And so, this is a deterministic process.
There is only like one possible answer.
However, as we said before, this is not
a bijective
mapping
because there might be many different
configurations that lead to the same end
effector.
And this is why the inverse kinematics
is a much more difficult problem.
Because this is like the problem that we
will mostly focus on in in this course,
which is, you know, like our policy
might predict a new target pose for our
end effector, and we need to figure out
which joint angles
Q will get us there. This is essentially
like inverse kinematics.
All right.
As I said,
like the solutions in inverse kinematics
are often non-unique.
Right? Like here you can see there could
be like two very different set of
joint angles that lead to the exact same
end effector position. And so, this is
why for many complex robots there might
not be an analytical solution
at all
to compute this.
So, in practice, um,
oftentimes like we use some sort of
optimization based
inverse kinematics where we
define a cost function like the distance
between the current pose and the target
pose and add some second secondary
constraints like staying away from
obstacles and so forth
um that
help us solve this with gradient
descent.
Um,
I will not go into too much details but
just kind of to get the gist of it. This
is how um at the most basic uh form
such an optimization based inverse
kinematics would work
um where we have this this error between
like the the current pose and the target
pose
um and we want to like minimize this.
Um, let's say with a squared L2 norm of
that error.
And um
for then the update um and then we kind
of
iterative
iteratively apply this sort of Jacobian
method um
that is just that tells us like um how a
tiny change in each joint angle
uh affects the position of the end
effector in the real world
um and nudge the the joints until the
end effector reach um
the target position.
All right. So imagine we have now um
solved we have found
um
we have run the optimization and found a
set of uh perfect joint angles that
reach our target position.
Um
but like how do we actually translate
this into motion because the robot will
just not teleport from one position to
the next, right?
Um, so in order to move this, uh, let's
say we will have the SO101 and we want
to move it like like 1 cm in like
sideways in Y direction, uh, we will
have to interpolate
instead of doing this this uh giant
jump.
Um, so for this we essentially want to
create a series of tiny way points
that will like move the end effector to
the target goal.
So this more simple way you could think
of how to do this would be just doing
linear interpolation
where we treat the joint space um
um as a straight line
um and so we we we also need to define a
time like what is the time we give like
our controller to reach that end pose
and then we calculate how many
way points or discrete steps
we need to take um and then
yeah we just like interpolate, right? um
and
so we care about this because as I said
before like in for the policy we will
uh we will have to like use some sort of
like way point generations to um to like
interpolate to the target poses our
policies produce.
um
However, um there is a an issue with
this approach if we do this linear
interpolation.
Uh and so while it's very simple um
and very easy to write down, it's
actually
pretty bad for our robot um because
this essentially means that you know it
will go to like full velocity at the
first time step and you know like
uh you see like this
like how like how this like velocity
looks
and it will produce like a lot of stress
also on the
uh on the robot hardware um
with um you know also with this infinite
spikes of acceleration, right? So it's
going like full on and then at the end
it's going like from max speed to to
zero like from one time step to the
next, right? So that's like pretty bad
um and so this is why um typically
instead of doing this um most
controllers do something
uh,
a little bit more sophisticated with
like some polynomial based methods such
as quintic splines. Um, the idea is that
instead of like doing like simple linear
paths, we you represent a trajectory uh,
of each joint as a fifth order
polynomial. Uh, and then you add like
um, like six boundary conditions um, um,
to ensure smooth motion. And so,
essentially you you encode that the
robot should start and end with zero
velocity and zero acceleration. Um,
so,
then the movement looks something like
this. You can see like it's a much more
smoother uh, like more gentle start and
also ends much more
uh, gracefully. Um,
and so, the also like the
uh,
Dirac delta uh, spikes are now gone.
Um,
and this is what, you know, a lot of
waypoint generation methods like
industry robots like Franka's will will
use.
Um, one last note on on robot control.
So,
we have um, determined how we can
generate like a set of uh,
like first like a set of um,
joint configurations and waypoints to
interpolate smoothly between them.
Um, but in the real world, um, the robot
will never follow um, these perfectly
just because you tell them tell it to do
it so uh, because there are like factors
like friction, there is like gravity,
uh,
air resistance and so on um, that will
make the robot not follow like this
waypoints perfectly. And so, this is why
um, typically um, you use like a PID
controller uh, to ensure that your um,
robot like is following this uh,
trajectory of waypoints uh, as much as
possible.
Um,
I will not go into too much details. I
guess many of you already have learned
this in other um
in other lectures, but uh I try to
visualize a little bit how the different
um
components of the PID controller work uh
when you actually um try to follow a
trajectory with the robot. Right? And
so, you can see for example here how um
so, the proportional is just like kind
of proportional to the error, the target
that you have between the the desired um
uh uh trajectory and the one your robot
is currently following, right? So, the
the further off you are, the the harder
it will pull you towards the correct
trajectory. Uh and then you have the
integral part, which will compensate for
example for things like gravity. If like
you know your robot is very heavy and
you know it's kind of like going down,
it will kick in and and pull you back
up. Um and then the for example, if you
overshoot, then the derivative will kind
of help you um get uh
dampen this and
uh go back.
All right. So, um so, now we know how to
kind of like this is a kind of a crash
course on how we can actually affect
motion with our robots and end
effectors, right? Uh it's a very basic
motion. Um
And the question is like, well, are we
now done? Well, obviously not because um
in in a in the real world, like a robot
needs to do more than just like
following a straight line. Right? It
needs to ideally decide um which action
to achieve or to take to achieve some
complex like long horizon uh goal, uh
especially when the world is uh
unpredictable, noisy, or uh unmapped.
And so, we have covered like kind of the
control parts uh in robotics uh
uh here, but now uh what we care more
about in this lesson is to the machine
learning part. Um Oh, I'd I'll take the
questions at the end. Um
Sorry. Essentially,
for the decision-making, to decide like
which is the the next action the robot
needs to take to achieve some complex
long-term goal.
This is an example for example from one
of my previous works
where we were doing sushi cutting as a
task with this by manual Aloha robot.
And so this is a a very long horizon
task where the robot needs to
first like grasp the
knife with one hand move it in the right
position then grasp it with the second
hand so it it will do like as you will
see in a second
um
this this this Okay, it's vibrate it it
still vibrates a little bit but you
know, and this is very very precise like
kind of like manipulation task, right?
Cuz now it needs to like go right Okay,
this is like a toy sushi. It's not a
real sushi but it needs to go right in
you know, in there and that's like very
very difficult for for a robot to do
this like so accurately and precisely.
And
and so this for example
has like 14 degrees of freedom, right?
It's like two arms
and it's like very high frequency so
it's like a lot of actions that your
policy needs to predict at every point
in time
to decide how to do it. And then you
have like the low-level controller like
the PID and all of that that that like
ensures that the motor actually follow
what your policy is predicting, right?
So now we will cover like the basic
mathematical framework that allows you
to learn such data-driven policies
to enable like policies to solve this
sort of like long horizon dexterous
tasks.
um
So,
maybe let's first talk about how we can
represent this mapping from observations
to actions and introduce some
terminology. Um this is typically not
too different from what you how you
might represent an image classifier
which maps from input X
to some outputs Y like for example here
for for for this like cute cat um with
the with a neural network. Um now a
policy maps from an observation O um
like here from this like camera view
from like a car um
from a snowy road to some output A which
in this case could be um actions that
tell the car how to drive like straight
left right or or backward. Um and so um
other than that the symbols like
essentially not not many things change
so far, right?
Um and we denote
pi the pi symbol we use the pi symbol to
denote the policy and the subscript
theta to denote the weights of of the
neural network of that policy.
Um
And so now typically in in a controlled
decision-making problem things exist in
a temporal context so
like at the instance time in T um you
know, I'm looking at my camera
observations O and
with subscript T and I will make a
decision based on that denoted AT. Um
and then the next time step would be
like T plus one and so forth. Um and in
this course we will use like integers
time steps which start starts at zero
and then go one two three and so forth.
Um but in the real world there could
also be like some sort of continuous
notion of time such as like milliseconds
for example. Um and so mathematically
Um, I said before a policy is just a
conditional probability distribution
over actions given an observation. Um,
and um
but there is a a big difference here.
Uh, in classification, if you mislabel a
cat as a dog, um, the cat doesn't
change, but in robotics, if your policy
chooses the wrong action, the state of
the world changes. So, if your car turns
left into a ditch, the next observation
that the network will see will, um,
obviously be very different.
Um
and in the most, uh, general case,
policies provide distributions over
actions.
Uh, so they will assign probabilities to
all different actions,
um, which we will call stochastic
policies, um, but there are also special
cases like deterministic policies.
Uh, they assign a probability of one to
to a single action and zero to
everything else.
Um
yeah, so we have to find a policy. Uh,
but what is a policy looking at? Um, and
so here it is important that uh, we
distinguish between states and actions.
So,
um, for example, looking at the car here
on the left,
um, like the state is is like the ground
truth. Um, let's say it's like the exact
position of the car on a map, its
velocity, orientation, and so forth.
Um, and then, um,
on the on the right, this would be like
the observation, right? So,
like the observation is produced by a
state. And this is like some sort of
like a lossy mapping, right? Um, and um,
the the key insight here is that uh
like no matter uh, what is the the
weather or or visibility,
um, you know, even if it's like, you
know, a
you know, like a snowy, you know, like
uh
uh, night driving, like um, the
observation might change, right? Like
the amount of information you're
perceiving from like the sunny clear
skies to this, you know, like very bad
visibility driving,
um, but the state doesn't change. So,
the state remains constant. It's It's
always the same. Um, and so,
this is important because like in
robotics, we typically operate with
observations, like images from cameras
that will give us like partial
information about the state of the
world.
Um, in the language of probabilistic
graphical models, we can describe this
as a following. Um,
so, and the policy pi will give us the
conditional distribution um
of A given O, and then the state and the
action together provide a probability
distribution of the next state. Um, and
this will call the transition function
or the dynamics rule. Um, and maybe one
thing to note here is
very important that maybe some of you
already have heard. Um, this is the
Markov property, which means that
if you are trying to determine
state three, so S3, and you already know
S2, then knowing S1 doesn't provide any
additional information that helps to
determine S3. And this kind of makes
sense because as we said, right, like
the state already like contains all the
information you need about the world.
So, knowing the past doesn't help you
like determine the the future. Um,
but still like even though you might
know the state, like predicting the
future might be a difficult due to
stochasticity.
Um,
maybe to confound you a bit more,
in this class we will mostly use the
terminology of S for states and A for
actions, which goes back to dynamic
programming
of like the '50s and '60s with Bellman
and so on.
Um, but
you might have seen it for example in
the in the
example I did for for the PID control,
that sometimes people also use the
notation of X for
actions. Sorry, X for states and and U
for actions, which comes from kind of
optimal control
theory. But this is exactly essentially
the same. Maybe the only thing you
should know is that for
like rewards and and cost function you
have like this this inverse
relationship.
Oops, sorry.
All right.
So, now the Markov decision process this
is the the formal framework um
um that, you know, kind of summarizes
everything we'll be talking about from
motor trucks to to high-level goals
and is defined by by this tuple over
here
with the state space,
action space, the transition probability
and a reward function.
And the reason why the MDP is
fundamentally so important is that it
provides us like a some sort of like
unit
unified mathematical
framework that allows us to treat
complex physical machines
exactly like any other computational
agent
enabling us to
to apply
the same learning algorithms
to a 27 degrees of freedom like humanoid
robot as we do for playing the game of
chess.
Um
Okay, so for the state spaces um
there are like two different categories.
This can be discrete or continuous.
So, for the discrete ones as I said for
example in the game of chess um
there is no no halfway between squares,
right? So, you have to like
you can kind of see everything. For the
continuous space state spaces, this is
what we will use mostly in robotics.
Like this will be like for example the
the joint angles and these are defined
by real numbers.
Um, and so um, this matters for robot
learning because in a discrete world,
um, an agent can essentially explore by
trying like every different buckets, um,
in its state space while in a continuous
world there might be a infinite number
of states. Uh, and so you cannot like
just build a table, um, for every
possible states and its value, but you
have to use like function approximators
and neural networks, um,
um, across like, you know, this infinite
possibilities.
Um,
uh, similarly, uh, talking about action
spaces and how they influence the world,
we have again the same um,
categorization between discrete, um,
this could be like for example like the
keyboard if you're like uh, controlling
like the robot in the simulator with the
keyboard, um, this would be like
discrete, uh, action space while if you
use, uh, for example like VR motion
controller to teleoperate it, this would
be a continuous and much, uh, smoother,
um, action space.
Um,
regarding the transition, um, model, um,
in in a perfect world our transition
model would be deterministic as shown on
the left.
Um,
so this means that if we command our,
uh, car to turn the steering wheel
exactly 5°, um, the car would like move
in a perfectly predictable arc. Um, but
in the real world, um, you know, there
is stochasticity. This means that it the
road might be slippery, there might be
ice, there might be, I don't know, the
tires are worn out, and so you might not
get, um, that exact predictable
behavior. And this is why, uh, in
robotics we often use this, uh, this
stochastic transition model, um,
uh, modeling. Right, for example with
the arm it could be as we said that the
motors overshoot or there's like some
uncertainty because of sensor noise and
so on that make like your
like robot not follow 100% like the
trajectory that you're predicting.
Um in MDPs we also define reward
functions which model the behavior of
the policy.
This is mostly used in reinforcement
learning setting
or paradigm.
Typically most of you might be familiar.
We can use either sparse rewards
that only happen at the end of an
episode or if certain conditions are met
such as one if the robot like lifts a
lifts an object and and zero otherwise
or we can also use denser rewards such
as the Euclidean distance
from like your end effector to the point
of the object that you want to grasp
which also accelerates learning greatly
and I have attached
the video doesn't play. I have attached
two examples from
my PhD
where I was teaching an RL agent to do
this
kind of like pick and place tasks and
here you can see the difference that
that this might make
when training like real world policies
with RL for robotics. So you can see the
the sparse reward one like
fails greatly while the denser reward
one
can pick up the objects and place them
nicely.
So I guess if we had trained the the
sparse rewards one like longer it might
eventually have learned it.
All right.
We have looked at the individual
components of the MDP, the states, the
actions and the transitions. But the
robot doesn't exist like in a single
moment. It operates in sequences and we
call the sequences or I already called
them trajectories.
And this is defined with this tau symbol
over there.
Um and um the trajectory probability
represents the
total probability of seeing a specific
sequence of uh states and actions.
Um so, essentially, it tells us like how
likely is a certain trajectory going to
happen under the current policy pi.
Um and um this is modeled by by these
three things: the probability, um the um
the raw is the uh represents the
probability of the robot starting at a
certain state. Uh then we have the
policy um at every state, uh like what
action does our policy choose? And then
we have the uh transition function. So,
given the action, where does the physics
actually land us? And so, by multiplying
these together uh for every time step,
we get a complete probability
uh of everything that could happen. Um
Okay, now that we understand uh how to
model a trajectory, uh we need to decide
for how long um should we care should
the robot care for in the future? And
this brings us to the concept of the
horizon. Um so, there are like two uh
categories, um
finite horizon MDPs, uh where a robot
might have a strict time limit um
um
to execute this task. Like, let's say 5
seconds to pick a a moving object. Uh
and, you know, once that that is over,
like the episode starts again. Um in
this setup, the robot might um
might change its strategy as it gets
closer to the
uh to the 5 seconds. Um so, it could be,
for example, learn like that at um
second four, it becomes more desperate
and goes, you know, for like a risky
movement or something to achieve the the
reward. And then we have um infinite
horizon MDPs, um where with which
technically um continue forever to
infinity or until a certain terminal
state um is reached. And this is like
more common in autonomous navigation or
long-term kind of tasks.
Maybe one thing to note here is that
like in principle just if you use like
this this formulation like there would
be no way for like the policy for the
robot to know which policy is better if
you accumulate like infinite rewards
over time.
And this is why we typically solve this
with a discount factor gamma
which you set between 0 and 1
to ensure that the rewards closer in
time will get weighted more heavily than
rewards in the distant future.
Okay, this is the last slide.
So putting all this together
how this is the learning objective to
finding optimal decision-making
policies.
So first you can look here this is the
accumulated reward
an agent might receive for either the
finite or the infinite infinite um
horizon over its lifetime.
So you can think of just like the sum
or the discounted sums um
of the agent. But then because the the
world is stochastic like we model this
as an expected return.
So
this average will return
like the average of across all possible
trajectories that can happen when we
follow our policy.
And then the optimal policy is the
specific strategy that maximizes this
expected return.
And
yeah so it could be like for example
this one over here.
And yeah.
I think with this we can uh,
switch to the paper discussions.